[Musique]
retour sur la visite de jacques chirac
dans les yvelines au terme d'une journée
de rencontre et de dialogue le président
de la république a été reçue au conseil
général des yvelines par les élus je
pense que c'est important pour tous ceux
qui vivent dans les yvelines de voir que
ce ce département est connu du président
de la république je crois qu'il a été
impressionné par la vitalité de
l'économie et de l'esprit d'entreprise
dans ce département
certains pourtant regretté l'aspect
édulcorée de cette journée je crois
qu'il serait important que à la fois on
voit ces entreprises performantes mais
qu'on a eu aussi en voir qu'ils sont
plus en difficulté qu'on en a ivoire des
quartiers très joli mais aussi aller
voir des quartiers qui souffle
j'aurais si j'avais eu la possibilité de
faire je l'aurais bien invité dans une
ville comme trappe voir cette réalité du
vigile c'est la coiffe franck borotra
reppelin son voyage était centrée sur
l'activité économique sur le contact
avec les entreprises sur les atouts
français en même temps ce dialogue avec
la jeunesse était très enrichissant et
j'ai trouvé ça
un message et une visite pleine d'espoir
jacques chirac a estimé en conclusion
que les yvelines était l'un des
départements les plus dynamiques de
france et que cette journée avait été
particulièrement instructif
il est un peu moins de 22 heures avec un
petit quart d'heure de retard sur le
programme la rencontre franco-allemande
s'achève angela merkel raccompagné par
le chef de l'état quitte la préfecture
des yvelines
la journée marathon s'achève vous savez
que depuis le général de gaulle c'est à
dire depuis le 16 juin 65
aucun chef d'état en exercice était venu
dans cette préfecture et donc plus de 40
ans après être venu pour un son une
réunion de cette importance à l'occasion
de l'inauguration de cette superbe
exposition des musées de dhr est au
château de versailles est bien pour
cette maison c'est effectivement un très
grand honneur
cette rencontre officielle se prépare
dans les moindres détails depuis une
quinzaine de jours tout a été réglé par
les services du protocole allemand et
français
la sécurité bien sûr mais aussi le choix
des salons en passant par les fleurs le
menu et l'emplacement des caméras dans
la cour après un entretien entre
délégations à huit clos angela merkel et
jacques chirac se présente devant la
presse il est aux alentours de 19h20 il
sera bien sûr question de la baisse de
la tva pour la restauration repoussée à
une date ultérieure mais aussi de
l'apprentissage des langues dès le plus
jeune âge
ahmed tape dans les mains il ya une
équipe sauf l'opportunité de commencer
l'apprentissage des langues dès le plus
jeune âge de venir dès l'école primaire
et je crois que le plus tôt on commence
l'apprentissage de deux langues le veut
cela serait même si pour l'instant on le
fait un peu trop tard en allemagne il
est indispensable de faire en sorte que
tous les européens amenant le plugin
possible soit dans l'obligation dès le
plus jeune âge à l'école apprendre d'eux
nombre et c'est le meilleur moyen de
faciliter la diffusion à la fois de
l'allemand et le français
[Musique]